what's up guys whereupon finiti today  we'll be trying to play table tennis on  different heights can't really hit so  hard yeah  okay this is my secret strategy  [Applause]  [Music]  ah  [Music]  is  [Music]  wait that's illegal I'm a doctor  [Applause]  it's my turn now  this is suitable for you  [Music]  oh you got it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  yes  [Music]  this this is actually quite enjoyable  you know what sort I think this is the  most comfortable way to play the game  the lazy man's take offense  [Applause]  [Music]  now it's your turn  [Applause]  imagine if you were like four meters  high and it would like playing table  tennis would feel like this  you will require a really good footwork  alright make sure to subscribe to our  channel here and watch our previous  episodes there until like five  what are you impressed by my skills good